if you're a basketball fan you know your
team's big stars head coach maybe even
the rookie Benchwarmers but you probably
know very little about the PhD
mathematicians like this one her job is
to crunch the numbers of the game we're
all in sort of an arms race to acquire
information and she's turning basketball
into a hard cold science my name is
Ivana Shelly and I'm a data scientist
[Music]
for many years Philly was a tough place
to be a basketball fan but having
reached the top eight in the playoffs
for second season in a row the 76ers
right now are in a renaissance just
across the river is where the team's
been hard at work and it's where I went
to go meet Ivana and April's this 125
thousand square foot facility comes with
all the features you'd expect from an
MBA training complex it also features
the office of people like Ivana to
support the team behind the scenes my
job involves analyzing the data that we
have from NBA games
my focus is mostly on the coaching
strategy the coaches have a lot of
intuition they know the game they know
the players but we try to complete the
picture of the players with data which
is hopefully unbiased
Ivana is part of the Sixers 10-person
analytics team the work of these
statisticians has already forced a
profound change in the game of
basketball teams are taking more
three-point shots even though we make
them at lower percentage than the shots
closer to the basket but they're worth
more points than the trade-off actually
pays off take a look at this clip from
the 80s see how all the players are
bunched up right by the hoop compare
that with today more and more of action
is taking place at the 3-point line
of course it's not just basketball
that's been reshaped by analytics
businesses of all kinds are tracking a
ton of information they never tracked
before thanks to new sensors
improvements in computing power and
plummeting costs and data storage data
scientists are the people making sense
of that information with a combination
of statistics and computer programming
the professions expanded rapidly in
recent years and comes with an average
salary of $130,000 a year much of the
data Ivana works with comes from
technology the NBA adopted in 2013 every
NBA arena has cameras that record games
and then film those cameras they can
extract player locations in a court
these cameras record 25 frames per
second so for each basketball game
there's a million of rows of data and
that allows Ivana to analyze plays that
were previously difficult to track for
example take the pick-and-roll it's one
of the most important plays in
basketball it involves one player
setting up a human shield to help a
teammate shake off an opponent so we can
look at each player how much they round
pick and rolls and how how good they are
at that and then we can select a player
and see how often he's gonna pass out
with the pick-and-roll help and he's
gonna shoot and how would that help you
develop a strategy for the coaches also
we could for example this player he's
gonna pass pretty frequently we can say
this to the coaches and they're gonna
decide on the defensive strategy for the
player but this makes it vaana's job
looks simpler than it actually is
because he spends a lot of her time
coding to extract the information she
needs and I tried really hard to get her
to talk about what exactly she looks for
and there's some stuff that you do
that's beyond just these interfaces that
you showed me today right yeah can you
tell me more about that
not really so that's that's like a trade
secret
yes MBAs are very competitive League so
whatever can give us that advantage
which other people when advising the
coaches with her analysis Ivana has a
decided advantage over many of her peers
I started playing when I was 7 years old
and I just loved it from the first day I
think because the game is so dynamic and
there's so many different skills like
what I wanted to do since I was 7 years
old really I wanted to be a professional
basketball player at 19 Ivana moved from
her home in Croatia to New Jersey to go
to college and a basketball scholarship
and while she was a star player on her
Division one team she was an exceptional
math student much of her life has been
like that balancing her love of
basketball with their love of math like
I almost thought I'm gonna have to
choose between the two I went to
graduate school and that's when I really
thought that okay this is really I'm
really choosing one or the other at this
time and so I I thought I really chose
just math the plan was to become a
researcher or a professor then three
years into pursuing her PhD in math she
heard that NBA teams were starting to
hire data scientists but only 26 percent
of data scientists are women and in
vanna didn't like her odds when I saw
the job posting I didn't think I would
actually get the job I thought because
being a woman in such a male-dominated
field I would they would never really
consider me give me a fair shot but this
prediction
turned out to be wrong she's got both
the technical and ocelot backgrounds
which is sort of the ideal mix her
ability to kind of capture these complex
insights and then share them with
players with coaches with executives in
a way that makes sense to us is super
valuable and frankly not that common the
next evening I attended my very first
NBA game it was the last game of the
regular season before the playoffs and
my chance to catch up with the ultimate
beneficiary of Ivana's work
the Sixers head coach Brett Brown
the team has had a great season so far
what role do you think analytics is
played in that's the best I mean I think
it's played a significant role in our
success and many many others the NBA
playoffs are gonna start in three or
four days and immediately we'll get sort
of an analytical assessment on the
strengths or weaknesses of an opponent
you can assess play calls good of bad
ones ones you should do more ones you
should avoid really I think it's going
to continue to grow and play a
significant role in the design of
organizations and coaching staffs
beliefs that night even though none of
the starting players played in the game
the Sixers ended up crushing the Bulls a
month later the Sixers ended up
advancing to the conference semi-finals
and suffered a tough defeat at the hands
of the Toronto Raptors ivana and your
colleagues will keep looking for ways to
help their team do better in the seasons
ahead but the Sixers victories on the
court won't be the only way she's
measuring her success it's it's really
exciting to be able to show young girls
that they can actually have careers but
it also feels like a big responsibility
because
if I don't do well it's gonna seem like
a woman cannot do this job because there
are not so many of us it's a big part of
what motivates me every day to be able
to to show young girls that they can
succeed in in STEM fields and in sports
you